it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd
and massive sunscreen nerd and today we
are talking about
zinc oxide sunscreens there are so many
myths around mineral or physical
sunscreens
these are the ones with zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide and how they're
supposedly better than chemical
sunscreens
these are the ones with scarier sounding
names like oxybenzone and octocrylene
and it's usually zinc oxide that gets
all of the hype
some of these advantages are true but so
many are just myths
and a lot of these myths are being
spread on social media not just by
influencers but by sunscreen brands
doctors
dermatologists cosmetic scientists and i
think these myths are getting people to
use sunscreens that aren't necessarily
the best option for them
i've talked about the pros and cons of
chemical and physical sunscreens before
with things like safety and irritation
and environmental impact
you can check out my other videos on
those but today i wanted to focus on the
myth that zinc
oxide sunscreens are actually better
sunscreens that they give better
protection against uv
i was originally going to cover the
other myths as well but then this video
ended up way too long
so that is future michelle's problem
i've also probably missed a few myths so
if you can think of any more leave them
in the comments
if you like sciency beauty content click
the like and the subscribe and the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos
first off i have nothing against people
using zinc oxide sunscreens if you
prefer them then
keep using them i just want everyone to
know the real benefits and drawbacks so
that you can make the best decision for
your own situation
i'm going to be calling the two types of
sunscreen chemical and physical in this
video
it's not great terminology and it kills
me a bit inside every time i use it
organic and inorganic are far more
accurate but
chemical and physical is what everyone
calls them so i'm just going to be a
sheep here
zinc oxide and titanium dioxide are
physical sunscreens everything else is
chemical
so zinc oxide being the most effective
sunscreen
the most common reason i've seen for
this is the myth that
zinc oxide works like a shield it
reflects and scatters uv while chemical
sunscreens work like a sponge they
absorb uv
this is probably the most widespread
myth about chemical and physical
sunscreens and it's not true
just like chemical sunscreens mineral
sunscreens mostly work
by absorbing uv and turning it into a
tiny amount of heat
about 95 of the uv that hits a mineral
sunscreen gets absorbed and turned into
heat
only about five percent gets scattered
if you want to learn more about the
nitty-gritty details of how sunscreens
work i have a video on that
i'm not sure why scattering is used to
make mineral sunscreen sound better
i think it's to do with how absorbing
sounds bad like it's not
really getting rid of the uv and it's
not as good as like a superhero shield
that darts around
and bounces off the uv i think it's also
confusion around the word absorb
because it sounds like chemical
sunscreens absorb into the skin
and that means that it's not really
protecting the upper layers which is
also a myth
but it doesn't really matter because
almost all of the uv is absorbed by the
mineral sunscreen
only a tiny amount is scattered now some
people might cling onto that scattered
five percent and still say that because
of that
zinc oxide is better but scattering
isn't actually as good as
it sounds most of the scattered uv is
actually scattered
forward so deeper towards your skin this
isn't really a problem because it
increases the chance of that uv
hitting another sunscreen particle and
getting absorbed but basically
absorption is actually really good
because it destroys the uv and turns it
into something less harmful
whereas scattering just sort of deflects
the bullet now this myth burst another
myth maybe we can start making like a
sunscreen myth family tree
a cursed family tree mineral sunscreens
are better because they don't produce
heat
well i've already said that there's only
a five percent difference in heat and
five percent is tiny
but zinc loyalists might say that five
percent still might matter
that heat still might contribute to
pigment and melasma so i did a test with
a thermal camera and some sunscreens and
it turns out that the difference in heat
is
undetectable the difference is actually
smaller than the difference in heat
between this part of your arm and this
part of your arm
there's also the idea that mineral
sunscreen specifically zinc oxide is
broader spectrum and so it protects
against more uv wavelengths unlike
chemical sunscreens
again this is probably like a cousin of
the shield thing
but it is partly true zinc oxide is a
broader spectrum ingredient
it protects against uva 1 uva ii and uvb
but not because it works like a shield
titanium dioxide is also a mineral
sunscreen
but it isn't very good at protecting
against the longer wavelengths of uva 1
unless it starts going white and there
are chemical sunscreens that can protect
against all three regions as well
but i guess it boils down to does a
broader spectrum sunscreen ingredient
lead to
a more protective sunscreen well no
broad spectrum just tells you about the
breadth of protection and not the
strength of protection
and the strength of protection is where
zinc oxide really falls short
sunscreen protection is a bit like a
wall zinc
oxide is a broad spectrum ingredient so
it's like a really wide wall it protects
against all the wavelengths
but it's not a very protective strong
wall it's a bit like swiss cheese it's
got lots of holes
so if you only have one layer of this
rather holy wall
then you can still get lots of uv
getting through you can imagine uv as
like
balls getting thrown against this wall a
lot of balls will still go through the
wall
chemical sunscreens are like narrow
walls without a lot of breath so they
only protect a small section
but they tend to be stronger so they
have less gaps and so they protect a
small section
but they protect that small section a
bit better so right now it seems like
both options aren't great
but we can improve both of them we can
stack more of these zinc oxide walls
together and so you end up with a lot
more protection all along the wall
this is the equivalent of adding more
zinc oxide to the sunscreen
different chemical sunscreens protect
against different parts of the uv
spectrum and so we can put up more walls
on different places
we're mixing different chemical
sunscreen ingredients into the one
sunscreen product
now the problem is we can't just jam in
an infinite amount of zinc oxide into a
sunscreen
we need other things in the sunscreen
product to help it spread out to keep it
on the skin
to stop it from feeling and looking like
chalk chemical sunscreens are soluble so
they feel a lot better than zinc oxide
and it turns out we can mix more
chemical ingredients into a sunscreen to
get a higher protection
than we can get if we just jam zinc
oxide into a product
there's been some new developments in
zinc oxide technology where you can
basically
get different shapes of zinc oxide
particles to get higher protection
but still the maximum you can get from a
zinc oxide only sunscreen
is still around spf 60 and uva pf20
with chemical sunscreens you can get sps
of over 100
and uvaps of over 60. if you look at the
highest spf rated sunscreens none of
them use zinc
oxide they all have a mixture of
chemical filters and titanium dioxide or
just chemical filters
which is another funny part of this
titanium dioxide
is actually a really efficient sunscreen
ingredient it gives much stronger
protection than zinc oxide
and a lot of chemical sunscreen
ingredients as well but poor titanium
dioxide gets ignored because i don't
know zinc oxides the golden child but
synchoxis still doesn't protect really
well
in the uva 1 region so if you want a
high uv a1 sunscreen then you kind of
have to go with chemical
so the whole zinc oxide is the only fda
approved ingredient that protects
against uva 1 uva 2 and uvb
it doesn't make zinc oxide sunscreens
more protective because you can mix
different chemical ingredients into the
one sunscreen and that means it can
block uva 1 uva 2 and uvb
it's like saying salt tastes good on its
own so plain salted food is the tastiest
well no because you can mix other
seasonings together there's also the
myth that zinc
oxide protects against blue light and
again it's more of that zinc oxide is
like a shield that protects against
everything for a sunscreen against
visible light you need iron oxides and
pigmentary titanium dioxide which has
large particles and looks white iron
oxides absorb visible light
pigmentary titanium dioxide scatters
light so it bounces it around the
sunscreen film
until it has a chance to be absorbed by
the iron oxides
again absorption is the bomb i don't
know if people still say the bomb
tinted products like foundations tinted
moisturizers tinted sunscreens
usually have both pigmentary titanium
dioxide and iron oxides so
they give the best protection mineral
sunscreens don't absorb visible light
and they don't scatter visible light
unless it's accidental
white cast is what happens when you have
scattering but mineral sunscreen
ingredients are optimized to try to
minimize that white cast
there is one study from color science
where the conclusion claims that zinc
oxide makes titanium dioxide and iron
oxides work better
but the data they show doesn't really
support this they test with four
products
three tinted sunscreens and one face
cream the formula with the least mineral
sunscreen ingredients and the lowest spf
actually gave the best visible light
protection so yeah keep in mind that you
can't necessarily trust the conclusions
of studies
you need to read them critically zinc
oxide is better because it works
immediately this one's a bit weird and i
think it's another bastard child of the
reflect versus absorb myth
i think people got confused between
absorbing uv and absorbing into skin
you might have seen this as chemical
sunscreens need to absorb or react with
skin to work and so you have to apply
chemical sunscreens 15 minutes before
you go out into the sun whereas physical
sunscreens work immediately
these are all myths both types of
sunscreen ingredients absorb uv straight
away you can see them absorbing uv on
paper here
but both tyres also need about 15
minutes to spread out
on your skin to form an even intact
layer so
you use them the exact same way unless
it's a special formula that's designed
to absorb into the skin like the heavy
sunscreens but
that's a completely separate issue
because it's more photostable
and therefore you don't need to reapply
another reason people give for zinc
oxide being better is that it's more
photostable which means it doesn't break
down in the sun
after absorbing too much uv whereas
chemical sunscreens do
now some chemical sunscreens can break
down in the sun
and once they've broken down they don't
work as well but there are a lot of
chemical sunscreen ingredients that are
photostable
this includes most of the older
sunscreen filters plus the newer
sunscreen filters that were specifically
designed to be photostable
and even the less photostable chemical
sunscreens can be stabilized by other
things in the formula
so for example avobenzone is pretty
unstable on its own
but in neutrogena's heliplex formulas it
still gives more than 85
uva protection after five hours of
midday sun exposure
for all sunscreens chemical and physical
you're meant to reapply every two hours
and that's because the sunscreen layer
starts to crack
and wear off sort of like how a
foundation breaks up over time
so five hours from helioplex should be
more than enough
there's a study that looked at how well
different sunscreens absorbed uv
after leaving them in uv for a while the
higher the line is the more it's
protecting in that region
the top two sunscreens have avobenzone
the bottom one has zinc oxide and
titanium dioxide only
you can see that none of them are
changing too much after uv exposure
you can compare that with a
non-photostable sunscreen like this one
now there are some arguments why zinc
oxide can actually be
less protective even with the same spf
reason number one
is people are likely to apply less zinc
oxide sunscreens
sinclair sunscreens have a lot of
drawbacks that are pretty obvious if
you've ever tried them they can leave a
white cast especially if you have darker
skin
and sometimes it fades away but a lot of
the time it doesn't and so you end up
walking around looking like you're
wearing
youtuber makeup they usually have a
pretty thick texture
zinc oxide is an insoluble mineral and
so texture wise
it's a lot like ground up dirt or rock
it's not great at absorbing uv
so a lot of the time in sunscreens you
need 10 to 25 percent
so you can imagine if you have like a
jar of moisturizer you're adding one to
two and a half teaspoons of dirt
into this the base of the sunscreen also
has to be pretty thick to keep the
particles suspended and spread out
and not let them sink to the bottom for
a relatively long period of time
so it's not a great setup for a product
that feels nice on your skin
and they tend to clog up pores as well
they're also usually pretty drying
because zinc oxide can soak up oil a bit
like a clay mask
on the other hand chemical sunscreens
tend to be a lot lighter
not always but it's a lot more doable
and they tend not to have a white cast
now all of this might seem superficial
and not a big deal
but cosmetic elegance is important a
little doesn't go a long way with
sunscreens
for a sunscreen to work you need to be
applying the right amount which is quite
a lot
and reapplying it often and you're less
likely to do that with a sunscreen
that's super white and super thick
a cerave survey found that 55 percent of
people who skipped daily sunscreen
did this because they didn't like the
way it feels during and after
application
38 said that white cast was an issue
there's also a study from
a sunscreen ingredient manufacturer so
flagging for possible bias but they make
both organic and inorganic sunscreen
ingredients
they found that people unconsciously
used 29 less of a 6
titanium dioxide sunscreen versus a
sunscreen that had 3
titanium dioxide and 3 of a chemical
sunscreen ingredient
you can also see a lot of reviews of
zinc oxide sunscreens online where they
say
it's really thick but a little goes a
long way which
just doesn't work the other big issue we
don't really talk about much with
mineral sunscreens
is stability and not photo stability but
just
regular stability for a sunscreen to
work well the sunscreen ingredients have
to stay spread out in the sunscreen
in the bottle during its lifetime plus
when you're applying it on your skin
plus when it's been sitting on your skin
for a while if it clumps up then you get
holes in your protection
most chemical sunscreens are soluble
which means it's mixed at a molecular
level
it's a little bit like vinegar when you
have vinegar the vinegar molecule stays
spread out in the vinegar for a really
long time
they don't eventually sink to the bottom
but when you have bigger particles it's
a lot harder to keep them separated for
longer you can use
a thicker texture with rheology
modifiers to keep the particles further
apart for longer
you can also coat the particles to try
to stop them from clumping
but at the end of the day particles are
always going to be harder to stabilize
than a solution or a normal emulsion
this is especially the case when you
have zinc oxide and titanium dioxide
they are really dense materials four to
six times denser than water
and so gravity wants to pull them to the
bottom and it's even worse when you have
uncoated zinc oxide which a lot of
natural sunscreen companies tend to use
because the coatings tend to be
synthetic zinc oxide itself is already
pretty synthetic but
they just don't use them these encoded
particles really want to clump up a lot
so these large particles tend to clump
up together and separate in the bottle
if you leave it for too long if you let
it get too hot
or if you apply it to your skin and let
it get wet and i think this is the
reason why a lot of mineral sunscreens
especially those from natural brands
that use uncoated zinc oxide
in a really oily base tend to get really
bad scores in consumer reports tests
they measure the spf after something
that's pretty similar to the water
resistance test
they apply the sunscreen to the person
they get the person to sit in water and
then they test the spf
and there are also lots of reviews of
these sorts of products from people who
got burnt while using them and i think
it's a mixture of people being more
likely to under apply
a really thick product and just the
unstable drama queen nature of
uncoated zinc oxide but i think if
you're aware of these issues then it's
fine because you can work around them
make sure you still apply the right
amount of sunscreen don't use it if it's
expired don't let the bottle get too hot
don't use it if it's separated so at the
end of the day is the same thing that i
keep on saying the best sunscreen is the
one that you use
if it's something you enjoy if it's
something that fits in your budget if
it's something that you can easily
access if it's something that doesn't
irritate your skin then it's going to be
the best sunscreen for you
it doesn't really matter if it's
physical or chemical and also remember
sunscreen is not the be-all and end-all
you can also use
other sun protective measures like hats
and clothing so hopefully i've covered
most of the myths about zinc oxide being
more protective if i didn't leave me a
comment with the extra myths
if you liked the video click the like
and the subscribe you can also follow me
on instagram and check out my blog
see you next time hopefully it's not
about sunscreen again but
i can't make any promises because it is
heading to sunscreen season
and you are going to see myths
everywhere